San Jose February 10 through 12 why you
love it there
I love Holman yeah whom is the best but
my ticket numbers there I used to sell
that [ __ ] wrong it just hasn't been
the same it's a big theater too and I
used to sell them on for God but now
it's better in the same part I compared
my numbers to Joe coins relate to be
honest or though he does so well he's
good at publicizing he does a thing
where he has an amassed email list well
you know it's from gabriel iglesias
fluffy he started thing years ago it's
kind of genius where you take a photo
you know how people want to take photos
but you do it with your own camera so
then they go to some sort of website or
Facebook or whatever they take the photo
but then you get an email exchanging you
know an email list I know but it's a
force email list it's a force to email
list but light and then they co in the
town damn mass over the years what like
hundreds of thousands of emails per city
then all of a sudden they're selling out
every show me
I don't do not them iPhone you know but
you don't because you also don't want to
I think there's a part of you that wants
to be a little more elusive you don't
want to be too mainstream there is a
little bit of that you're right I think
there is a little bit of me just kind of
going I'd rather I like I like kind of
just showing up and being weird and I
purposely weird yeah I mean like I'll
just walk up to a waiter and go bang guy
at ball and there's walk away and they
go what the [ __ ] you know and then I
like um I know also and I'm not gonna
Pat myself on the back but I've always
been good to local comedians and I'm
gonna tell you a story I'm not gonna
name the guy okay but my host okay this
kid named Josh he always hosts for me in
San Antonio he requested another comic
who I'm friends with who's as probably
bigger than me and when he picked him up
from the airport he
hey dude I'm also M seeing your show and
the guy go no you're not because why cuz
like because I don't want you on the
show and so they might then Josh dropped
him off at the hotel and then walked
away all sad and like and when I hear
comedians treating other younger
comedians that way
it [ __ ] drives me crazy because the
thing is is this and it's been like this
through the history of [ __ ] time okay
is is that these comedians like I told
you about Judd Apatow and Jeff Garlin in
Addison in nineteen the club I'm playing
this weekend there is a file cabinet in
the office and it says old lineups they
have lineups from the 80s and like just
like in this file and I opened up just
one random one 1990 because that was the
year I graduated from high school and I
saw Diane Ford headlining nobody knows
who the [ __ ] she is but Jeff Garlin from
kirby enthusiasm was featuring Judd
Apatow was em saying okay let me tell
you this right now okay
I don't know how what die afford I'm
port probably nice lady but if she
wasn't and she was a nice to Jeff Garlin
and Judd Apatow back then do you think
that they would ever help her when she
needs it ya know right that's why like
kids like Jack night I know is gonna be
a big star - hands down yeah a lot of
these kids you never know so you know my
thing is just be nice to everybody be
supportive if they have advice and there
is something about there was this little
Asian kid in San Antonio he was like you
small he remind me of a Pikachu from San
Francisco and he was there I took him a
diner like a bunch of comics he's in and
out of comedy like he doesn't know you
know but you know he's asking me
questions I give him direct answers and
it's like you're be at service it
doesn't cost you anything to be nice to
these younger guys it really doesn't it
doesn't anything yeah and a lot of these
headliners they treat them like [ __ ]
the things I hear I don't know why they
do that and I kind of when Josh told me
that this OMC I said I'm gonna call my
Justin please down I was in almost in
kind of but I wanted to I wanted he's
he's a friend of mine I want to call him
go dude what the [ __ ] are you doing what
are you doing
you know you're first of all number one
he's not that big of a star you never
mean he's not Chappelle he's my level
well you're at my level you can't afford
that to be like that and I was at the
airport to you know to this morning and
there's a lot of military kids 18 and I
don't know man there was just so kind
and I hugged them I love hugging
military kids no I do I do I really um I
really am grateful for their service
[Music]